what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are gonna start Cobra Kai season five
episode one today John how you doing I am
very excited how are you Andrew how are you
I'm doing well and congratulations you guys
on joining your two dojos would have shouted
out that you got us these shirts if you just
waited geez congratulations congratulations
on congratulating yourself now the shirts
have lost some meaning because you wanted
the praise so badly you're welcome that's what
uh that's what we do in Cobra Kai we strike
first we don't wait for Chris yeah don't wait
for compliments all right ladies and gentlemen
uh we don't want to talk for too long on any
of these because we just kind of want to binge
this show since there's so many episodes that
are out and it's already a crazy film weekend
with plenty of content coming your way but guys
subscribe and click that notification Bell to get
notified when our reaction for the next episode
of Cobra Kai is up leave a like that would mean
the world to us right about now also full length
Reaction watch along as we sync up with your own
copy of Cobra Kai available for super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page lastly the
team at prepper thank you guys for helping
us edit down these highlights you guys ready
Born Ready all right Angie you better catch all
them Easter eggs every single one I'm a failure
within every punch and kick lies centuries
of tradition it has a rich past and now we
want you to become part of its future
welcome to call for Kai what the [__]
down our dog show is committed to
providing state-of-the-art training
this commercial was expensive we
believe anyone can be a winner
all you need is the right teacher it's
a new era at Cobra Kai come join us
We join in it's crazy some of those camera angles
they got from the tournament for the commercial
be it one with the water I
can find Mrs Larusso chosen
call me crazy but I thought
maybe we'd be having my ties
by the pool not watching your Okinawan
assassin use it as his training ground
can't wait for Samantha to see him naked
lawsuit you need some help I think you
can help me get to 137. uh you're
done fine giving me some patience
all right there you go and how
much you want to pay for the bag
it's messed up man
this figure a reward might be in
order yeah since we found your
bag I'm a real Mexican and more like discount Thor
oh good here take it off what you didn't
think I'd take all your money did you
really learning that Miyagi do a way
of not striking first anymore paralyze
that guy got some Choice supplies
for the next leg of our road trip
Mexican Cokes
I got you a little something to say
welcome to Mexico don't tell me it's
offensive we bought it in Mexico it's their idea
it's logic I'm shutting down Miyagi do
karate or with everything going on at
Cobra Kai continuing to operate need to only
Target on your backs this Dojo may be closing
but miyagido lives inside each and every
one of you still Miyagi dough is not a place
it's up yet it's Samantha's fault right because
she lost it's definitely 100 all my fault
fight this is this is Sam I know firsthand that
silver isn't afraid of putting kids in arms away
and I have to keep all of you out
of it you think it's permanent
definitely definitely only
one episode this season yes
questions
so I use the f-bombs on the show I know where
the kid gets off the bus so that's our first
stop and when we get there what do you plan on
doing I'll ask around if anyone saw me go start
with the Australian guy Terry silver this is how
everyone sees them as some kind of philanthropist
out to save the kids of the valley that's why
you're here we have to cut the head off the snake
I can do that cut off one head two more show
hey well literally cut his head off for cutting
blocking and stabbing and growing
silver may be crazy but he's not dumb
he always thinks two moves ahead
you have to be careful with this guy
more than your son he must be careful with
this guy oh [__] you're stuck in here with me
I didn't realize there was a camera
just right up in their face when they
were filming the Terry silver money
they got cameras everywhere in town
just all drones circling you're not telling
anyone where you were going yeah well I know
if I told you I was going you're trying
to stop me because care about you your mom
and grandma left Ecuador to get away from your
dad they probably did it for a good reason I I
[__] rude beat him up Miguel
you're not gonna ask if I won or lost
how are you making this about
you right now I'm not I oh
there are more important things
than karate Sam yeah there are great
he is way better looking I'm out here trying
to fix my mistakes so I don't have to live
with the regret of making them if you're
serious about making things right you can
start by helping Miguel I know you have your
fair share of regrets when it comes to him
kicking him off the top of that
do a whole flashback of guilt
this is what I was afraid of
Cobra Kai's enlisting kids who have
no idea what they're getting into
um so I can part three I have seen
these moves before you have where
song yeah yeah Kim Sung young South Korea
oh [__] that's a real person I thought
it was just some mumbo jumbo silver came
up with no that's racist it's very real
my uncle Sato did not speak much of Kim
Sonia but I know he had much anger towards
him you guys carry this conversation pause
the conversation we carried on the dojo
Kim Sung young was Master of a Tang sudo but
that is not what he taught his thought was a
controversial what was controversial about
it I would demonstrate you will be paralyzed
Kim song is based on Deception no honor
no mercy he could have just told me
we will use his start against him
how will we do that I feel like Daniel could have
probably guessed what Terry silver learned from
his master you know just think of the worst
version possible that's all about aggression
McHale's got a brother
eliminate him fight him foreign
don't trust him he's a fierce killer guy says
he thinks he saw Miguel talking to these Surfers
sorry I dragged you into this Robbie Johnny
and the Surfers that's going to be fun
good enough before a kid 17 Ecuadorian slight
build but we're working on that have you seen it
yeah
he's heading here
oh yeah yeah oh damn all right Miss what's the
scam give me some bum address try to steal my
wallet we've got five seconds to tell me which
way that kid went I'm gonna take that surfboard
and I'm gonna shove it so far up your ass your
friends are gonna be surfing you oh nicely done
do it
damn yeah
I'm not fair hello wow
damn yeah oh my God
don't scam my people I was sick
I'm following them this guy
carries himself like a drug lord
thank God that cliche panned out foreign
this is strange I feel like we've met
somewhere before I'm about to cry sperm count
keep track of my sperm Ranger but tonight
your family okay okay come on it's a regular
Olive Garden down here Carmen said he was a
very evil man I could see him but he could
have a super hot stepmom now you're right it
was a mistake to bring you here no it wasn't
okay I mean some goodness technically kidnapped
and transported a minor across the border but we
got a good story out of it hmm but I'm gonna stay
I'm trying to make things right I want to help you
at least now we know where we're
going x marks the spot right all right
all right oh all right let him put his arm around
him this is just the beginning we're strangers
but I can tell you we won't be strangers for
long damn my dude's got a nice house he's evil
Cobra Kai now has more students than ever before
that means we'll need more senseis I'm going to
pay more than what's expected but first you must
prove yourself in The Way of the Fist let's
see him it's time to see if you're worthy hey
welcome to COBRA Kai oh yeah buddy infiltration
you knew it oh so good clever clever dude
all right well we got more to watch it's a super
quick thoughts we're gonna immediately film The
Next Episode um Andrew yes do you want thoughts or
some Easter eggs whatever whatever Easter eggs are
part of the thought all right well just really
quick couple things I noticed when they had car
trouble with the tire there was car trouble in
Karate Kid Part Two and uh he blamed Ali with
for the brakes or whatever which was mentioned in
uh season three with Elizabeth Shu boom uh we also
got uh the bonding trip between Robbie and Johnny
they mentioned in season one how we never had a
family bond a father's uh Sun bonding trip so I
had to make one up now we finally got one uh we
saw Terry silver beating up some of his lackeys
when he was uh just doing some training we saw
that in part three when uh we saw crease at the
beginning of part three meet Terry silver in that
film so there's a little reference there and then
also we finally heard uh Master Kim Sung young I
mean they showed the reference back from Karate
Kid Part three so that was cool to get that back
of South Korea so I'm really curious to see how
we're gonna see that all play out in this because
I'm remember that was just a lot a kind of a
throwaway line but really curious to see that
but in regards to this episode I loved it was
a good introduction to starting season five I
really like how they harped on the consequences
of what happened at the end of season four just
in terms of Cobra Kai winning and now Miyagi do
shutting down how it affects everyone and then I
love Miguel's storyline too and discovering
you know who his father is I'm sure there's
going to be some ulterior mode or you know we're
going to see something different with his father
I mean there's obviously like I know it's we're
seeing a nice it looks like he's a nice guy but
to me it seems like something else is going to be
there but I think my favorite part of this episode
for sure was Johnny and Robbie I love seeing I
mean the dichotomy of their relationships so far
in the Four Seasons I mean it's really been
understandable from Robbie's perspective for
through his father you really feel sad and bad
for him but I really love seeing them together
they have such good on-screen chemistry together
you really feel that father-son Bond and I'm glad
to see them finally rekindling that relationship
yeah yeah the season didn't feel like the season
starter you know when shows when they do like a
final season and then they do like a part A Part
B like it's part of the same season yeah there's
like a little bit of a break in between that's
more what this star felt like to me it didn't
feel like brand new season five it just feels
like oh part two of season four or something like
that and I actually really like that Vibe it feels
like a really strong continuation of carry on the
themes of uh parental troubles and trying to keep
that all going but of course continuing with this
very specific fight against Terry Silver's Cobra
Kai we still haven't even checked in with uh
John creese yet but I already feel like we're
getting more substance from Miguel then because
I liked what we got with Miguel last season but
this one episode alone was like oh this is more
of like the Miguel I've been craving remember
that guy was just a nerd he is grown I don't
even look at him like a dweeb that one scene
he had with Johnny uh where he was where we were
really tearing up I mean that was so emotionally
powerful yeah yeah now we're now we're checking
in with him in this storyline I'm really I'm
really liking it I feel like there's more to
come with that but they're just really this
whole episode is just a good planting of seeds
you know with Samantha what she's going through
um again challenging the audience to be a likable
character I feel like we've always been the ones
who've liked her and then she seems to be like
such a divisive character for a lot of people team
Amanda I um Amanda a team Sam Sam Team all the
women in the Larusso house no Samantha's I have
noticed that there tends to be a discourse around
her when I'm like even like that moment right
there where she was on the phone with Miguel and
that to me it was just it's kind of like a real
thing that would just happen it's a real thing of
when you get into an argument and then you feel
like why are you making this about you I'm calling
you about a very specific thing about me that's
just a real thing it doesn't bother me I don't
know a lot of people seem to have like crap with
her and I don't really have any subscribe or maybe
I've just misread into it but I've seen really
pretty sure I've seen like a lot like there's
definitely there's definitely crap about her yeah
with Samantha I don't know she's fine to me and uh
I I I'm really enjoying the Miguel storyline the
most uh personally like whenever we're checking
in with her it feels very refreshing and different
but that knows how to like balance that storyline
with going back to some of that fun 80s action
um spencil cheese that you love from Cobra Kai
when trying to take down Mr Silver Johnny Boy
all the things you guys said uh yeah no everything
you said and I love the just juxtaposition of the
Mexican setting versus everything we have going
on at home I just love the flavor that that brings
I like the scenarios that that brought up and
you know Miguel's sort of haphazard search for
his dad feeling like you know like he he finds
him like within two people but at the same time
letting it be sort of a difficult journey within
the confines of a half hour episode and having
that initial fake out interaction like I thought
that was good I love the stuff with Johnny and uh
Robbie and yeah just the whole chosen thing too
like he's so confident that the outset that I'm
like I know this is gonna become a mental and a
physical and and an everything challenge you know
like a whole challenge of Will and character for
him and yeah that line up at the end when Terry
Silver's walking down you know addressing the
soon-to-be potential sensei's you get to that
last shoulder on Like It's gotta be him you know
and yeah it's just such a rewarding but also like
horrifying Prospect because yeah that theme I
think is is going to come heavily into play is
you've got to think like your enemy and you have
to be willing to lower yourself into the muck and
I think that's going to become very challenging
as they go into the Vipers 10 basically so I
couldn't be happier yeah sorry I was just going
to say I really like to one last thing for me I
really like too how Daniel's influence in season
four really has you know kind of really gone on
to Johnny because I mean in that fight at the end
when he was fighting discount Thor and those other
guys I just felt like you know in the past Johnny
would have just struck first and just fought those
guys right away it was you know kind of like
letting them come to him kind of being more
in defense mode I know Robbie kind of you know
those guys were about to hit him and Robbie came
but again just feels like the influence of Daniel
is really rubbed off onto Johnny from season four
from their time together in season four well with
training Eagle angan uh evil eagle Eagle thing and
uh and the Miyagi dough and I really appreciated
that moment that continuity there that was really
awesome so I like that why not to me that's what
I mean by how this just feels like it's going if
it feels like season four part two yeah um already
like I feel like we had other than like a couple
of different haircuts no time jumps or anything
yeah it's just continuing directly yeah this feels
like the next episode and I think that's a really
a really solid start I feel like that if there's
anything that Cobra Kai does exceptionally well is
its consistency and that which is on Full display
here yeah all right guys well we're just the very
very beginning of the journey as this show said
so uh we're gonna watch episode two before
we go let's do a patron of the day shout out
hey Fox foxy Fox gonna see you back
here again so we've been looking at
people's names in Urban Dictionary and um
I gotta tell you your name is weird yep
so it says um Urban dictionaries where it's not
mine I don't want to get canceled it says a noun
a beautiful and attractive woman she's a stone fox
cold so I'm not saying you're beautiful in a truck
nor am I saying you're the opposite of that I I'm
just saying that that's what Urban Dictionary is
you know let's find another Urban Dictionary
is hitting on you um okay here's another one
here's another one a hottie wow I mean every
time I've talked about you I've always met but
you know again I'm not the Urban Dictionary is
the one we didn't write these entries all right
um okay acute orange Sly animal you know I've
always thought you were a bit of an animal I
don't mean like that you were Sly I've always
thought you were like like the next definition
a smart Sly person like John was doing something
yeah very smart person I understood that later
uh and yeah you're a smart Sylvester Stallone
yeah and hey that's that's the kind of person
we want to attract it to patreon all right you're
the perfect representation okay here we go we got
a great definition for you here we go here we go
oh yeah um it says a small animal animal that says
okay
tongue face what does the fox say about that if
you ask me that we're seeing more towel and your
existence with the Falcon Punch Falcon Punch
I have never gone to know you better I always
knew your sexy hot Sylvester Stallone ass who's
always at our patreon page I knew that was you
as you especially when you kept asking me to
read the script for the Samaritan I was like
I want to do that nah man that sounds stupid I
already know it's like two movies fused into one
but we love you fox and others in a
friendly way thank you for being here